[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue les vaccinodromes
vont-ils permettre d'accélérer la
vaccination sont ils la solution on vous
pose la question ce soir sur twitter et
on va en débattre voir débattre avec
béatrice giblin bonsoir béatrice dans sa
rédactrice en chef de la revue hérodote
et qui vient de publier son nouveau
numéro consacré au maghreb ça vient de
sortir et bien sont bien entendu c'est à
lire à lire également le figaro
d'aujourd'hui de demain est toujours
d'ailleurs sur le site sur le figaro.fr
alexis on revient dans le figaro dans
les prochaines heures sur les présidents
de croissance avec les états unis qui
s'envolent qui est à la traîne et on
retrouvera également dans l'est dans les
prochaines heures on parlera du dvq
cynodrome et on vendra également des
cinq ans de la république en marche et
oui j ai aussi avec une question autour
du bilan à quoi sert vraiment ce parti
fondé un an avant la victoire triomphale
des manuels macron à la présidentielle
s'est il vraiment installés dans la vie
politique française vous dites ce que
vous en pensez on en débat mais d'abord
un chiffre un objectif 12 millions
d'injections d'ici la fin du mois soit
autant que ce qui a été injecté depuis
depuis la première injection à maurice
est le 27 décembre dernier les autorités
le promettent la cadence des
vaccinations va augmenter avec
aujourd'hui l'ouverture d'un centre de
nouveaux centres de vaccination géant
c'est vous allez le voir sur ces images
donc dû vaccinodromes du stade de france
l'initiative a d'ailleurs été saluée par
plusieurs élus locaux et des saintes
saint denis notamment eric coquerel qui
on a posé la question est-ce vraiment
une opportunité
peut l'être à une condition c'est que ça
soit pas au détriment des centres de
proximité et même qu'on renforce les
centres de proximité pour une bonne
raison c'est que chacun comprendra que
c'est parfois compliqué notamment pour
les personnes âgées justement qui en
seine saint denis en plus souffrent
beaucoup de la fracture numérique
c'est pour ça qu'on a critiqué le fait
qu'on passe par des plateformes type
d'octo libre et non pas directement
c'est difficile pour des personnes âgées
d'aller jusqu'à justement un stade qui
parfois loin d'eux alors les personnes
âgées également peuvent se rendre dans
d'autres centres qui s'ouvre ce sont les
hôpitaux militaires et voici ce que cela
doit apporter selon le porte parole du
ministère des armées sept hôpitaux
militaires qui sont mobilisés deux près
de paris ii en région paca ont un
bordeaux à brest et un à metz donc très
concrètement dans chacun de ces hôpitaux
militaires sont ouvert des centres de
vaccination et chaque jour se seront ni
le français qui pourront se faire
vacciner dans chacun de ces hôpitaux
donc au total par semaine ce sont 50000
français qui seront vaccinés par des
militaires du service de santé des
armées avec 49 mines sur les soupçons
selon les calculs sont justes mais enfin
alexis là tout le monde est d'accord les
chiffres s'envolent ça y est on va on va
s'en sortir on vit dable seulement
formidable moi je me souviens de
l'époque pas si lointaine on ne faisait
que jamais jamais au grand jamais la
france ne ferait des vaccinodromes que
c'était pas dans le génie national que
de faire des grands machins qu'on
n'allait pas faire des fermes et des
gens faire la queue sur des débuts
centaines de personnes offert comme si
on faisait la queue au coude à coude
dans les vaccinodromes ce qui n'est pas
du tout le cas je me souvient d'un temps
pas si lointain où les mères tel david
lisnard à cannes ou ailleurs qui
installés chez eux des structures
collectives comme ça se faisait
engueuler ça faisait même peut on les en
tout cas se faisait menacé de traîner
devant la justice parce que ils
s'affranchissent est des consignes qui
était uniquement les la médecine de
ville et puis après on a fait on a dit
mais jamais les les pharmaciens puis on
a mis les pharmaciens puissent jamais
les blacks sidro maintenant enfin avec
cynodrome tout c'est formidable je pense
qu'on va finir quand même à force à
force de prendre du retard on va finir
par y arriver
donc oui tant mieux c'est très bien il
faut maintenant que les vaccins arrivent
il semblerait que ces deux vaccins sont
en train de se débloquer
quel retard qu'elle retard on appris
béatrice
finalement malgré le retard maintenant
on va s'en fait d'un retard relatif
parce que quand on regarde le
pourcentage la plus simplement au sein
de l'europe je mets de côté le royaume
uni bien sûr mais si je regarde
l'allemagne c'est moins la proportion
est plus faible que la nôtre je regarde
la belgique c'est plus faibles si je
regarde les pays bas s'est encore
nettement plus faible on est à 13 et
quelques uns 13,8 je crois les pays bas
sont à 9,3 sur les chiffres que j'ai
regardé sur coville tracker qui je crois
est un site assez sérieux et sur des
chiffres qui étaient relativement récent
c'est pas les plus récentes des récentes
bien évidemment mais disons qu'ils ont
une semaine donc c'est un retard que je
constate mais qui n'est pas aussi énorme
à l'échelle de l'europe évidemment si je
le compare aux états unis vous venez à
35% de la population qui a été vexé mais
les états unis sont un état
et la première
c'est un état fédéral c'est pas dans des
camps quand le luron vaste et rome mais
10 milliards sur la table pour faire
avancer les accents c'est un chef d'état
va pas contester que le 30 mai
lorsqu'elle sort au nom de live nation
c'est non mais c'est pas en mettant
j'allais dire on vous l'a bien vu le
changement combats y donne est arrivé je
dire ça veut bien dire que le rôle de
l'état fédéral existe parce que sinon on
aurait vu aucun changement ni avec 30 ni
avec bayonne or on en a vu un donc si on
en a vu un c'est bien parce qu'un chef
d'état peut intervenir alors survolé
vaccinodromes ben je veux bien on aurait
pu en ouverture mais sans vaccin je
trouve que c'est pas très intéressant y
compris même les vaccins dans les grands
centres comme il y avait dans les
gymnases comme il y avait certains
endroits ils ont dû fermer souvent parce
que il n'y avait pas de vaccin faire
c'est vrai que lucas au stade vélodrome
à marseille
bien sûr nous dire que notre retard est
relatif moi je veux bien mais si on
regarde alors les beaux israël bien sûr
100 % de la population ont été vaccinés
au royaume uni 46 % et s'est excusé on
est très loin derrière le chili et le
chili on était 1er match on est très
loin évidemment déjà les états unis
derrière la serbie dire que les états
qui en europe s'en sont mieux tirés sont
les états qui ne sont pas dans l'union
européenne c'est comme si des rangs on
est d'ailleurs la hongrie on est
d'ailleurs singapour on est derrière la
finlande alors la semaine dit la
slovénie font mieux de vous alors c'est
vrai qu'à l'intérieur du petit noyau
européens ont eu tous grosso modo kuga
tout raté non
alors on va peut-être voilà on va bien
on va on va peut-être mettre le micro
d'alexis à la pile d'alexis qui aiment
tomber mais béatrice on va vous laisser
répondre et peut-être on va prendre des
questions on va prendre des questions
d'internautes et je prends d'ailleurs
des premières réactions d'internautes le
temps guillaume remettent la pile dans
le micro d'alexis je pense que les
vaccinodromes n'était pas forcément
utile les pharmacies les supermarchés et
autres endroits très fréquentés aurait
rendu les choses plus simples les files
d'attentes moins importante voilà une
première une première réaction
par rapport à ce que disait alexis
béatrice oublier réagir
oui parce qu'on peut toujours regarder
ce qu'ils font mieux et puis on peut
aussi regarder dans des fonctions
similaires regardez ce qu'ils font
nettement moins bien je reconnais que
l'europe n'a pas et tout le monde le
reconnaît y compris les responsables
européens a manqué qui lui considère
qu'il a tout bien fait que tout était
formidable ah ben oui on a deux
attitudes ceux qui trouvent qu'on fait
toujours tout mal et puis ceux qui
trouvent qu'on fait toujours tout bien
c'est à peu près le même type de l'homme
je disais que les responsables
reconnaissaient ce qui n'a pas bien fait
dans la halle dans la mesure où par
exemple la présidente de la commission
européenne l'a dit dans la mesure où on
a macron qu'il a dit ou on a un certain
nombre de gens qui le reconnaissent
merkel ou autres bons en disant qu'on
aurait pu faire mieux alors maintenant
bas on va regarder mon année on peut
toujours battre ça coûte mea culpa mea
culpa j'aurais dû mieux faire une fois
que c'est fait on va regarder ce qui se
passe et je trouve qu'en ce moment
heureusement dieu soit loué si j'ose
dire en cette période de pâques c'est
qu'on a effectivement une amélioration
parce que les vaccins arrivent à partir
du moment où les vaccins arrivent on
vaccine alors il reste des réticences en
france dans une partie de la population
qui s'est affaiblie heureusement mais
elle résiste encore une ville qui m'est
chère qui est la ville de calais il
s'est trouvé sur mille possibilités de
vaccins 400 personnes qui ont 430
personnes qui sont pas les vexer faire
vacciner et c'est resté comme ça donc il
ya encore un travail à faire de pour
convaincre et les aides soignants et des
infirmiers et une partie de la
population à les vacciner c'est évident
et en forme du travail le résultat tout
ça est malgré tout et les prévisions du
fmi dont on parlait à l'instant on
apporte la preuve éclatante
c'est que ce retard en termes de
vaccination il a des conséquences
sanitaires sur les videmment la santé
des gens puisque plus on tarde à signer
plus il ya de gens qui sont malades et
malheureusement qui meurent mais ça
aussi des conséquences terribles en
matière économique c'est à dire qu'on
est en train de se rendre compte que les
états unis vont sortir de la crise à une
vitesse folle alors ils ont mis beaucoup
d'argent sur la table
mission aussi vacciner donc ils peuvent
sortir de la crise que les anglais vont
sortir de la crise et une très grande
vitesse que l'asie est déjà sorti de la
crise et que malheureusement notre bonne
vieille europe va être à la traîne et va
être
il est à craindre en tout cas que sont
englués dans la crise pendant encore de
longs mois pendant que les autres en
sortirons etc et caracole rond devant
eux c'est les provisions du fmi oui oui
mais les prévisions ne sont pas toujours
justes d'abord et du doigt donc non je
vous assurer que le fmi se trompent non
je ne pense pas que l'ayant fait me
semblait trop perfectionner vous qu on
espère qu'à moi je ne suis pas sûr un
discours et c'est pour ça que vous
m'amenez souvent à discuter avec alexis
parce que je pense que le discours
absolument tout le temps négatifs qui
est qu'à ça fonctionnait on peut aussi
regarder comme toujours le verre à
moitié plein ou le verre un match
évident bon j'ai plutôt tendance à le
regarder à moitié plein quand alexis a
plutôt tendance à regarder à moitié vide
ce qui permet de faire un débat
d'ailleurs tout à fait intéressant donc
moi je pense qu'on peut avoir aussi un
rebond il ne sera pas celui des états
unis bien sûr mais nous avons aussi une
structure sociale qui n'est pas celle
des états unis et ou amortir la crise
telle qu'elle a été avec les aides qui
ont été données a été quand même
beaucoup plus fort même si les
populations les plus défavorisées sont
les plus touchés on parle toujours de la
seine saint denis et c'est vrai mais
comparé à la situation d des états unis
ça n'a rien à voir et sur la masse
d'argent qui est mis
c'est un peu logique qu'on en met pas
autant dans la mesure où on a aussi une
structure comme je le disais dead social
et d'accompagnement dans des entreprises
que de la population qui fait que la
comparaison est utile mais elle est à
prendre avec une certaine prudence alors
il ya deux autres points peut-être pour
alimenter le débat est ce qu'on aimait
alors mettons qu'on reçoive suffisamment
de doses que les vaccinodromes s'ouvre
que les français aillent se vacciner se
faire vacciner en masse est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un autre problème serre que la
vaccination a beau être efficaces les
vagues personnes vaccinées peuvent être
porteuses du virus et contribué à sa
diffusion dans des proportions qui ne
sont pas encore aujourd'hui connue c'est
pas moi qui parle c'est le conseil
d'état dans cette dans cette ordonnance
du 1er avril dernier
et qui a rejeté donc une demande
d'autorisation de déplacement pour une
personne vaccinée est-ce que
je crois pas que devenait conseil d'état
qui a des dimensions vertu
soit habité dit même prétendent avoir
d'un avis médical il cherche simplement
à trouver une raison juridique
vaille que vaille pour expliquer à
quelqu'un que tu es vaccinés qui peut
passer cette personne que les personnes
vaccinées ne peuvent pas s'affranchir
des ddd discipline qui s'impose à tous
et donc cherchant à quelque chose ils
disent oui bat façon oui vous attaque
siné mais si ça se trouve vous êtes
contagieux donc vous devez continuer à
porter le masque jusqu'à présent ce que
deezer là il a joué de leur métier clin
d'oeil côté là ce que disent tous les
scientifiques c'est que dès qu'on lui
une population avec sid et d'ailleurs ça
se voit au royaume uni par exemple les
comptes a mission tombe les maladies
tombe les
présences à l'hôpital heures animation
tombe donc non je crois qu'on va dire
certains aujourd'hui rien ne permet de
dire que les gens vaccinés transmettre
la maladie simplement le conseil d'état
cherche un truc pour dire aux gens ne
fait pas n'importe quoi tout de suite
toi c'est comment un royaume uni par
exemple il n'est pas question d'aller se
déplacer partout pour tout pour le
moment
certainement pas de quitter le
territoire c'est hors de question ni
même de circuler d'un bout à l'autre de
la grande bretagne c'est pas du tout
dans et aujourd'hui on joue toujours pas
au golf au royaume uni on ne fait aucun
sport à l'extérieur sauf dans le cadre
de l'école l'école vient de rouvrir très
prudemment pour les plus jeunes mais pas
pour les plus grands c'est à dire qu'on
dessert avec énormément de prudence
c'est d'autant plus justifiée que comme
on a vacciné tous azimuts sans prendre
d'abord les plus âgés je pense à des
gens de ma famille qui sont en
angleterre 90 ans n'ayant pas encore eu
sa deuxième dose donc étant dans une
situation encore d'incertitudes donc
chacun effectivement il va être aidé à
m'en on a cité un exemple dans une ehpad
du sud de la france où il y avait des
personnes âgées ayant été vaccinés qui
ont eu de nouveau le coct locaux vides
bon 3 4 cités sur un ehpad on va
toujours en trouver voilà je pense que
vont il faut rester prudent encore
quelques dans ce parcours des cadres
ainsi gecas à 90% reçu ce jour 20 ou 10
exactement et puis par ailleurs entre le
monde on
subit la dose et le moment 15 jours 15
jours donc pendant ces quinze jours là
on peut retomber malades chez qui a
toujours dit mais enfin malgré tout
l'exemple britannique montre quand même
que ça marche et la façon qu'ont vu les
britanniques d'aborder cette affaire
me paraît extrêmement locaux du point de
vue de réaction comment dire de 2,2
démantèle des peuples face à face à des
crises des anglais ont pris tous les
risques qu'ils ont un forme de riz ils
ont ils ont investi massivement ils ont
pris des risques financiers ils ont
repris des sanitaires en disant on va
écarter les deux doses ils ont autorisé
des vaccins qui ne l'étaient pas ils ont
fait tout ce qu'ils ont fait tout ce que
l'europe
perclus dans ses règlements
bureaucratique n'a pas voulu faire aux
force est de constater aujourd'hui dans
les fêtes que l'attitude britannique est
une attitude audacieuse courageuse ils
ont confiné beaucoup plus tard que nous
en descendant très longtemps il portait
pas de masque sans valve simplement et
même 130 mais dans son cas on les a pas
encore les 100000 mais avec nessbeal à
peu qu'il fasse à l'adversité et fait
preuve d'une sorte de courage et de 2 et
d'inconscience à un moment oui mais il
disant mais pas nous mais quand vous
parliez de faire à votre vie des watts
et place est un peuple qui a fait preuve
d'optimisme qui s'est dit allez on y va
on va là ils ont eut ils ne cachent pas
ils ont eu à un dirigeant boris johnson
un bon mais qui n'est pas tout moi je
peux vous dire que je connais un certain
nombre puisque j'ai de la famille en
grande bretagne je peux pas ils se
tiennent pas du tout nouvel discours que
du bon mais ceci étant ceci étant cette
seule courage cette audace etc s'est
aussi traduit dans un premier temps par
une forme d'inconscience de nier ou la
gravité il a réactivé nalako si gentil
les fanfares de la conscience en dix ans
en gagnant à la glace c'est pas de la
médecine
je suis père est enfermé enfermé pendant
qu'on s'enferme et on ne va pas faire de
vagues on va pas distribués mais regarde
on va pas l'écarter des doses regardons
les deux lignes lamidat on est trop on
est trop prudent l'europe est trop
prudente passera sans doute l'europe et
sans doute trop prudentes est ce que on
a sans arrêt le principe de précaution
parce qu'on est 27 parce qu'on n'est pas
un et qu' il ya toujours à ce moment là
des attitudes et des comportements qui
vont être différent et trouver le en
plus la commission européenne n'était
pas en charge forcément de la santé il
s'est passé quelque chose qui va être
intéressant d'ailleurs c'est que cette
pandémie a fait avancer un certain
nombre de deux domaines dans au fond à
terme espérons le une forme de
simplification et l'idée que on n'allait
pas aller chacun tirait de son côté mais
qu'on allait travailler ensemble lorsque
ce qu'on a vécu va avoir une portée
historique dans le sentiment des
populations des peuples européens
vis-à-vis de l'europe on se rend pas
compte mais on verra dans les années qui
viennent je pense une rupture c'est que
l'europe au fil des arts n'avait pas
réussi à susciter l'adhésion l'affection
l'amour des peuples c'était quelque
chose qui était là que les gens paient
pour les jambes trouvé peu de sentiments
affectifs comme les poux par rapport à
son pays mais disais bon run an mal an
il vaut mieux être là et ça nous protège
on est plus forts à plus nombreux qu'à
moins nombreux c'est cette idée donc
c'était parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'attachement mais y avait le sentiment
que malgré tout vaut mieux y être dedans
que dehors hélas pour la première fois
face à une situation qui est la même
pour tous les mêmes faits les mêmes
problèmes
20le le benchmark comme on dit la
comparaison fait qu'un solution sealys
bas il vaut mieux être dehors dehors que
dedans et ça avant que l'europe se
remettent de ça ça va être très très
très long on peut assister à une rupture
historique des peuples à vis de l'europe
c'est la première fois qu'on se dit je
pari vaut mieux eh bien regardez les
anglais rêver les gens disent bien
regarder je regardais dessert je ne
partage pas je serais bien étonné de
savoir le nombre de gens qui ont envie
d'être serbe au jour ne parle pas du
voyage à mur oui mais je suis ravi que
cette clé
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous je ne
pense pas forcément que sa valeur
renforcée mais je ne pense pas que ce
sera cette faille historique
de d'un
désaffection définitif sur leur glace de
friandises mais il n'ya pas que la
pandémie il ya ce qui est en train de
monter dans la puissance chinoise et le
comportement des chinois qui inquiète de
plus en plus la population et qui voient
ça comme une menace incontestablement il
y a je crois l'idée pour un certain
nombre que effectivement on a pris du
retard mais je reviens sur les 130 mille
morts en grande bretagne quand on est
qu'elle soit 1000 avec une population
moindre gueule à d'autres donc je sais
pas si c'est forcément l'idéal donc je
n'aurai pas cette même lecture que vous
vous êtes vous aurez peut-être raison
j'espère que vous aurez très bas on
l'espère tous mais en tout cas l'europe
qui avait la possibilité de faire la
preuve qu'elle protégeait a fait la
preuve qu'elle n'avait pas supprimé la
santé n'étaient pas dans les noms de
domaine que les états n'avaient pas
voulu accorder à l'erreur et il pas dû
lui donner mais j'en sais rien toujours
est il que vous pensez très sincèrement
alexis je sais pas chacun avait été dans
son coin pour faire un certain nombre de
choses ça aurait été beaucoup mieux et
j'ai franchement continental on a réussi
là où l'europe échoué non il a d'abord
raté et après en catastrophe et des
documents son pays s'en sortira plus
vite je ne sera plus fort et qu'il est
en mission du fmi sur le royaume uni
n'ont rien de merveilleux je vous
propose justement bien de continuer à
observer ça dans les dents les prochains
jeux et dans les prochaines semaines
mais merci en tout cas le débat est
passionnant je vous donne les
réactions des internautes richard sur
youtube la vaccination de masse a permis
au royaume uni aux usa israël de stopper
ou au moins réduire les chaînes de
contamination baisser la pression sur
les hôpitaux en faire réduire
significativement le nombre de morts
donc oui c'est une excellente initiative
richard répondait justement la question
de savoir si c'était une bonne
initiative d'avoir lancé les
vaccinodromes chardon bleu c'est la
meilleure solution les vaccinodromes ça
marche très bien le problème c'est pour
prendre des rendez vous on y colle alors
là effectivement pense plutôt qu'un
lexique eux comme béatrice en tout cas
on a la preuve que l'europe est un frein
pour beaucoup de choses je vous propose
d'avoir le de continuer ce débat au long
cours dans les prochaines semaines
encore parce que je pense qu'il y aura
d'autres occasions de l'avoir la
question c'était les vaccine dont
vont-ils se permettre peut-être on
pourrait dire à votre internaute que
maintenant il ya un qui s'appelle vite
ma dose qui dépend effectivement de kobe
de trailer et sur laquelle on peut
facilement trouver à côté de chez soi
l'endroit dans les 24 48 ou trois jours
pour trouver un endroit où aller se
faire vacciner le srec 100
correspondants évidemment aux
différentes tranches d'âge qui va rien
de public non c'est une
mais qui réclament d'avoir forcément
tout c'était pas une objection technique
emea chez les lycéens heureusement qu'on
a désigné attendent
donc certaines conditions hâtives privé
de
mire l avance h à redon bleus
donc il justement posé la question des
rendez vous je vous propose donc de
dans venir deuxième question d'un
anniversaire c'était il ya cinq ans et
alors ils n'imaginaient pas à l'époque
ça c'est une certitude qu'on connaîtrait
la crise sanitaire qu'on connaît
actuellement
c'était à l'époque la création d'un
mouvement dans lequel peu de gens
croyaient en tout cas parmi les
observateurs cinq ans plus tard le
mouvement compte plus de 300 députés son
chef et à l'elysée alors les mauvaises
langues disent que la république en
marche c'est emmanuel macron plus des
gens qui ne sont là que pour distribuer
des tracts ont elles raison ont-elles
tort à quoi peut bien servir en marche
voici avant d'en débattre la réponse de
deux de ses responsables le porte parole
roland lescure et le délégué général
stanislas guérini c'est aujourd'hui
l'anniversaire on se souvient tous ou en
était il ya cinq ans moi j'étais à
montréal l'heure n'est ni à la fête ni à
la nostalgie bon un anniversaire c'est
aussi le bon moment pour revenir sur ce
qu'on a vécu mais aussi avant tout pour
se projeter sur l'avenir donc l'idée
c'est de remobiliser les troupes de
resserrer les rangs de préparer les
échéances qui viennent départementales
régionales au printemps
présidentielle législatives dans un an
je reconnais volontiers que en marche a
eu tout à faire en même temps on s'est
créé à l'occasion de l'élection
présidentielle a dû mener un travail
d'implantation accompagner et défendre
l'action du gouvernement et puis aussi
c'est vrai regarder vers l'avenir et
produire des idées mais c'est vrai que
nous avons eu parfois du mal à faire
exister ses idées dans le débat
politique et ça reste un enseignement
pour être peut-être davantage au fond
c'est
béatrice convient d'entendre jean
lescure députés des français de
l'étranger est ce que lrm s'est pas
d'abord le parti de ceux qui regardent
vers l'extérieur vers l'étranger non je
crois pas je crois pas tu vires tous
partis à des députés
de l'étranger non je devais même pas
posé la question pour pas que vous
fassiez l'objection est ce que c'est le
parti de l'étranger mais
justement
madame en gt500 heureuse de la
mondialisation non je ne pense pas bon
c'est évident que ça a été la carte
électorale du vote pour
macron oms élection présidentielle de
2017 montre bien que c'était dans plutôt
dans les villes et dans les métropoles
qu'on avait et dans une population on va
dire entre 25 et et 50 ou 55 ans une
population active plus tôt diplômés
enfin tout au moins avec une formation
qui venait d'ailleurs pas mal de la
gauche socialiste qui a voté bacrot à ce
moment là c'est indéniable c'est
incontestable bon et puis il ya aussi
tous ceux qui votent ni pour les uns ni
pour les autres
sans aucun doute non mais je pense que
c'est on dit toujours ils ont perdu les
municipales ils vont perdre des
régionales occitan à sont sans aucun
doute c'est un mouvement puisqu'il ne
doit pas dire parti mais qui est très
jeune cinq ans je n'en sais rien quand
vous comparez aux autres partis français
même le rassemblement national il sait
1970-71 sa création donc ça fait 50 ans
la c5 en jet il est un peu comparable à
ce qu'a été le rassemblement du peuple
français créés par de gaulle en 47 il a
c'est de 47 à peu près à 55 mais les
deux dernières années c'était déjà pu
très brillant avec alors là la
différence succès aux municipales succès
aux cantonales bon donc on pouvait dire
c'est un ancrage on y est bien et puis
d'aider des législatives où ils ont vu
100 députés sont espérés 200 on en avait
moins à l'époque il en espérait 200 donc
ça a été la défaite et puis après ça a
été un échec sur échec canto au
municipal suivant ils ont perdu plus
presque la moitié des mairies il avait
gagné c'est à dire que c'est difficile
de 200 crêpes dans la durée et voilà
c'est tout ce que je veux dire par
rapport à des partis comme le parti
socialiste qui est réduit à sa portion
congrue avec une histoire qui est
centenaire avec le parti de l'ump il a
changé de nom en face elle-même qui
évolue plein plus des airs rpr les
républicains aujourd'hui donc voilà et
puis c'est pas un parti de militants ce
sont des gens qui sont arrivés je finis
juste qu'ils sont en en balles et
j'allais dire par un pack macron mais
sont pas 35 ans didier qui distribuent
des tracts non il n'ya jamais ou presque
jamais personne de la république en
marche que j'ai vu cette tête au marché
où je vais mauvaise et pas vu déjà plus
grand monde aujourd'hui qui distribuent
des tracts mais elle remarche ans n'ont
jamais distribués oui je suis là c'est
le grand échec du maquereau nice mlle
les fêtes d'échouer alors il ya des
succès un côté de ça mais le fait
d'avoir échoué c'était le pari de
maquereaux départ une guerre il voulait
gagner pour les présidents pour
gouverner ça c'est la campagne à venir
qui permettront de se faire un point y
aura divergence sur la vie qu'on peut
avoir le nez ce qu'on peut porter sur
l'action gouvernementale action des
mails ma collection de ses gouvernants
mais dans son pari il y avait
d'installer de faire exploser le clivage
droite-gauche vérifie alors et
d'installer ou en lieu et place au coeur
du visage politique une force qui serait
la force centrale est dominante de la
politique française il a plutôt réussi
la première partie là le clivage droite
gauche et la droite la gauche a donc de
se produire mais ce qu'il a l'échec
absolu c'est de remplacer sa part un
parti qui s'installe car le salon c'est
peut-être cournon je crois que là je
plus personne n'y croit y compris mâcon
la reine ne s'est pas installé là rien
n'a pas d'installation locales vont
chercher des références vous parlez du
rpf et les repas fait gagner des
élections locales ce que n'a pas mis
en exergue sont sympas dans les
luminaires ses 58 de gaulle à partir de
58 va en très peu de temps installé chez
elle à droite bas droite non il y avait
les indépendants il y avait plein de
choses avant ces deux boules basta les
son parti qui va devenir une force
massive pendant quasiment un demi siècle
alors sous différents noms lui nerfs le
rpr jusqu'à jusqu'au juste que l'ump
puisque tout ça c'est des avatars de
l'est mais il va installer après 58 une
force et on aurait put être tout il ya
que de gaulle puis à personnes autour
les caciques de la quatrième république
aurait bien voulu et les indépendants
auraient bien voulu continuer il ya
plein de vieux parti qui aurait voulu
continuer et le mrp et compagnie
compagnie et de gaulle réussi lui mais
bon voilà après chaque époque et comme
elle est a réussi à imposer un parti qui
est devenu ultra dominante dans le
paysage politique français avec ce
qu'ils chantent bien sûr rires même
chose enfin même chose toute chose
toutes choses égales le on parle du ps
le ps créer une sci fi home health if
you et en étant alors qu'il reste plus
rien de la série il n'y a plus rien
quand le ps va être créé le mythe avec
le ps il faudra dix ans pour qu'il
prenne le pouvoir mais très vite son
parti comme la ritaline
il avait déjà même quand on crée le ps
il y avait des élus il y avait je pense
aux normes techniques je peux quand même
comment marche a récupéré une orchidée
élus n'ont passé
enfin le jeu bah ils n'ont pas récupéré
de mairie ils n'ont pas récupéré deux
cantons excusez moi mais ses filles au
qui passe au ps vous avez un maillage
franchement là c'est faux c'était plus
grand show mais est ce n'était plus
grand chose mais l'ancrage territorial
il existe
de comparaison absolument mais quoi
qu'il en soit quoi oui mais enfin quoi
qu'il en soit on l'a on a quand même
deux exemples de par deux parties qui
ont réussi à s'imposer on pourrait
parler de la progression du front
national verra qui est lente progressive
et dont l'ancrage local et fragile c'est
à dire que x aujourd'hui encore la
fragilité du front national s'était que
c'est un parti qui existait en tout cas
jusqu'à un passé récent essentiellement
à la présidentielle et qui entre deux
présidentielles disparaissait donc c'est
très important de s'implanter localement
d'avoir des élus ainsi
des parcours est bien en marche n'a pas
réussi bon c'est comme ça
mais ça veut pas dire que macron va
échouer non c'est deux choses
différentes on peut être élu sans parti
gouvernant parti il n'a pas fait la
démonstration après sa rencontre vers
naissant parti qui gouverne avec une
très forte majorité s'est pas exactement
la même chose faites attention mesdames
et oui mais quand vous êtes excusez moi
mais quand vous êtes le parti au pouvoir
parti en tant que tel vous êtes quand
même beaucoup plus une chambre
d'enregistrement quand exactement
exactement c'est sale c'est balisé et
est donc ces messieurs c'est la
constitution des nations c'est pour ça
que peut-être que dans les dents dans
l'exaspération que suscite parfois le
maquereau nisme les oppositions très dur
et notamment les gilet jaune et on en
verra d'autres déceptions comme ça elle
ses opposants sont peut-être dû au
hiatus qui a précisément entre l'absence
d'existence locale de ce parti qui n'a
pas représenté donc pour les gens qui
n'existent pas et la toute puissance
qu'il a au niveau national a traversé
députée et sacrée à hiatus qui est
asiatique et facteur de tension et moi
je pense qu'il ya eu aussi le fait que
avoir l'étiquette la république en
marche avec vous avez été élu au
législatif de 2017 et qu'une certaine
facilité a dû jouer dans les autres
sélections six ans bon on est candidat
on va y aller et puis ébahis ça a été un
échec je rêve ou partager certains
commentaires d'internautes et avoir
quelques objections par avoir ce que
vous dites
la première
objet que la première observation qui
est fait par beaucoup d'internautes sur
twitter eric nous dit le parti
disparaîtra dès que macro ne sera plus
au pouvoir c'est ce que nous dit kris
kross s'en macron le mouvement mort a de
lui même
oui c'est possible c'est possible ou si
une autre alors il ya une autre
objection mais macron peut même vivre
sans le mouvement est d'ailleurs c'est
bien son projet si on a bien compris la
vie en dix en train de réfléchir et une
maison commune ans qu'elle aurait
mélangé tout un tas de choses parce
qu'au fond il je crois même y compris
macro et les stratèges du maquereau nice
ont renoncé à s'agiter sur le cadavre de
la règle pour refaire un parti dominant
cette option là je pense n'est plus sur
la table pour le prochain le bras je
sais pas mais il n'a pas voulu faire un
parti or un parti s'il n'a pas une ligne
bien défini il n'y a pas un congrès ont
réuni de temps en temps les différents
membres des différentes régions et
départements pour décider si ça
s'organise pas comme ça c'est pas
qu'avec des réseaux sociaux qu'on fait
et qu'on fait en partie soit on fait un
parti et on a une structure deux parties
est à mon sens ils ne l'ont pas encore
là vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec eric
zemmour c'est cette thèse justement dans
cette nouvelle chronique
mais là c'est la ccal vêtements ou de
l'analyse politique furent donc
et qui développe vous allez pouvoir le
voir pouvez le voir derrière sur le site
dans sa nouvelle chronique où il dit que
en marche je suis également là la
tendance d'un certain nombre de partis
qui perdent des adhérents et que
peut-être que c'est aussi là un
tournant dans l'histoire des partis
politiques et de maquis que la fin du
parti de militants soit dans les tuyaux
depuis longtemps c'est un fait il ya
plus de militants au ps y avait plus de
militaires perrier emilia même pas de
militants front national en vérité le
parti de militants n'existe plus mais là
on attaque la mise sans militants sans
structure et 100 élus à la partie qui a
ni militant ni structure venir un sens
aigü locaux le covan c'est ça le sujet
ne s'est pas de pas avoir de militants
le modèle du parti de militants semblent
alors peut-être pas pour toujours mais
en tout cas durablement derrière nous
les gens ne s'engagent plus aujourd'hui
comme autrefois les parties de
structures plus la vie sociale comme ça
a pu l'être par le passé les gens vont
de l'ain vont viennent et se rapproche
d'un parti ou d'un candidat ou un an des
élections bien sûr deux élections ils
sont surtout au moment du récit ne s'est
pas la question de que des militants la
question celle des élus locaux
ya quand même une autre objection de
vous faire c'est par exemple me pierre
de 10,1 mouvements artificiels comme le
montrent les résultats aux municipales
ok et peut-être sans doute aux
régionales néanmoins contrairement aux
attentes le parti a montré aux
européennes il résister et à ce moment
là il ya une analyse qui a été fait qu'
il avait capitalisé
une partie de l'électorat effrayé et
braqué par la révolte des gilet jaune
est ce qu'il n'ya pas là une force pour
ce parti là bas
mutatis mutandis serait qui assemble de
gens peuvent voter pour demain pour des
candidats la reine le premier d'entre
eux macron la présidentielle où les par
peur du front national ben oui mais
quand on a plus que comme ça l'argument
la peur soit de la révolte populaire
soit dès l'élection d'un candidat
populiste c'est un peu court malgré tout
pour bâtir quelque chose de positif
c'est oui sa chance c'est qu'en face il
n'y a rien qui pisse à part le front
national ou à par le front national et
on peut peut-être voir encore aux
prochaines élections présidentielles
une réaction comme vous venez de la
décrire en disant non pas le front
national donc je vote mâcon on peut
avoir aussi une abstention forte qui
serait une façon de donner une demi voix
à l'un ou à l'autre ce qui posera
effectivement des problèmes importants
mais la question aussi qui se pose on
parle de la rems est parfaitement
justifiée puisque c'est l'anniversaire
des cinq ans mais c'est qu'en face ni à
gauche mais à droite on a quelque chose
qui permettrait effectivement de
s'accrocher et de et de mobiliser ce qui
fait aussi si vous voulez pour l'art m
une absence presque de motivation à se
battre dans la mesure où tous les
sondages les mémés les amène à ed avec
soi qu'un côté un capital ok serpent qui
se mord la queue après il y aurait un
candidat
crédible avec la stature qui surgissent
traîne enthousiasme dans le corps à soi
droite soit à gauche mais ça changerait
donc ce qui manque à droite c'est pas
les partis c'est le candidat est donc un
candidat sans parti peut gagner à partie
sans candidat ou durablement ne peut pas
tenir très longtemps il peut tenir cinq
ans et puis plus méchant il faut qu'ils
suscitaient candeur mais un parti qui ne
suscite pas candidat et keith absence de
neuf mois mais on peut tout à fait
imaginer que si demain un délégué des
candidats de droite ou un autre de
gauche arrivent à s'imposer à ce moment
là tout le réseau d'élus locaux qui
aujourd'hui sont un peu en marge des
républicains en marge du ps se airs
feront masser à ce moment là on dira il
ya un party les républicains où il ya un
parti pc mais il y aura toujours pas de
militants ça sera pas les vieux partis
comme autrefois on prend sa carte mais
il y aura une force politique dont il y
aura une force politique et puis aura
pour un temps sans doute une
mobilisation militante
fête ses 5 ans estimez vous que le
mouvement est bien implanté dans le
paysage politique français et
vous estimez pas du tout à
79% ils sont en train de réfléchir à des
nouvelles formes parce que toujours une
nouvelle fois encore se trouver des
causes
il faut choisir des causes pour
s'engager donc on bat chaque 1000 1 mais
toujours des causes optimiste 1 est
positive
que poser
d'experts est positif les opprimés donc
si vous avez un sujet qui pas positif et
pas aux petits vices faut pas faire
comme ça peut pas
jouer le verre à moitié plein voilà
c'est ça je t'ai le parti du verre à
moitié plein ils ont tort je ne fais pas
de mal non à l'occasion de cet
anniversaire on pourra recommander le
livre de notre confrère willy bordas
tout ça pour ça justement qui es-tu un
examen il raconte l'action des députés
la république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale effectivement c'est parfois
assez cruellement tous les cas c'est
très bien racontée et vous pouvez
retrouvez également la chronique d'eric
zemmour et qui revient également sur les
cinq ans de la république en marche
merci beaucoup on se retrouve demain
même heure même endroit avec carl meeus
chloé morin et gabriel cluzel peas elle
a très vite sur figaro live
[Musique]